stay away from me
she's in the battle dimension we have to
go in and get her back
[Music]
did it
we can't go out the way we came in there
are no other doors here I thought we
were walking into a trap the down
dimension doesn't function like the real
world to navigate through this place
we're gonna have to use our imagination
what imagination you are nuts we have to
say Vienna so I'm getting out of here
oh we're not gonna get her out that way
well mr. imagination what are we
supposed to do remember how I always say
that Dino Rob gets weaker the more we
count down in top five yeah I think it's
time I show you how to do the Mario hey
Paisano's it's the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show my name is Walter benezia for
months I was trapped in the evil Dino
ROVs Dino dimension a place where I was
duplicated dozens of times eventually I
managed to escape but now die rob is
sending his army to take me back with
the help of my friends he fight them off
and hoped to ultimately take down mr.
rage dinosaur then what we countdown the
weaker he gets this is top five the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show was a
huge success when it first aired in 1989
and well beyond its star pro wrestling
manager kept in the well bono as Mario
and Danny Wells as Luigi
the show usually opened and closed with
short live-action segments that featured
Mario and Luigi in their Brooklyn home
trying to get by with their plumbing
business almost every episode had a
guest star and some of them were pretty
well known at the time the bulk of these
episodes were the 15-minute cartoons in
the middle they covered the Mario's
protecting Mushroom Kingdom from King
Koopa and his minions the series ran for
65 episodes while all of them featured
live-action segments only 52 played
Mario cartoons the remaining 13 featured
The Legend of Zelda animated episodes
that played every Friday this show was
absolutely meant for little kids there
wasn't much to be invested in if you
were an adult or even teenage Mario fan
back in the day however it has a real
charm to it that is undeniable the
live-action segments especially showed
off a strong chemistry from its leaves
along with the cartoon some of them are
still entertaining to watch all these
years later but which are the best ones
these are the top 5 best Super Mario
Brothers Super Show episode
number five slime Buster's this was a
parody of Ghostbusters and one of the
more involving live-action stories Ernie
Hudson guest stars as he and Mario try
to exercise an evil spirit that has
possessed Luigi sticking to the
Ghostbusters theme it's a very slimy
evil spirit this was good old cheesy fun
like the whole show it's extremely dated
but that's part of its charm I mean just
look at early Hudson in this as the
episode goes on
Luigi's possession worsens until he
starts physically transforming
[Music]
The Legend of Zelda cartoon the ringer
aired along with this but for Mario
related fun this live-action segment is
an entertaining little piece of
nostalgia that's short enough to still
get a kick out of number for defective
gadgetry
it's the crossover we never knew we
wanted in his first live-action
appearance Maurice LaMarche plays
Inspector Gadget he goes to the Mario
Brothers for help in fixing his
malfunctioning gadget potty but they
aren't very well-versed in fixing broken
cyborgs so high jinks ensues what do you
say expected what's that how long have
you two been working for the evil dr.
claw
oh yeah order the production company
deke put out both this show and
Inspector Gadget so a crossover with
their biggest character at the time must
have seemed logical admittedly it's a
bit surreal seeing gadget on the screen
ten years before the Matthew Broderick
movie in any case it made for a zany
light-hearted and somehow historical
episode of the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show by the way where did you find
my new spare parts oh I got them at that
novelty store run that thirty-third
thing a novelty store right gadget would
reappear once more in the live-action
segments treasure of Sierra Brooklyn
unfortunately that episode is extremely
difficult to track down with both gadget
episodes featuring a Zelda cartoon
instead of a Mario one they're missing
from the Super Show DVD set before we
move on I should mention this episode
also features the first live-action
appearance of dr. Mario are you ready
dr. Mario number three flatbush koopa
slash opera now this was an interesting
episode of the cartoon King Koopa and
his forces have finally been defeated or
so we think
with Mushroom Kingdom seemingly saved
the Mario Brothers find a way back to
their home of Brooklyn however when they
arrive they see that King Koopa has
already been there wreaking havoc for
some time he's even remade the Statue of
Liberty in his own image it's now up to
the Mario's to save their home before
Koopa and his troopas completely take
over while a lot of these cartoons can
feel pretty lackluster and even cheap
this one stands out and breaks the
status-quo almost all of the animated
episodes take place in the Mushroom
Kingdom
so it was a nice change of pace to see
Mario and Luigi have to fight Koopa on
their home turf we see battles at Coney
Island and the Brooklyn Bridge
while Koopas plan is uniquely weird
turning everyone into bricks his troopas
are hilarious in the story I can't get
enough of that voice I know it's pretty
much Marvin the Martian but the fact
that all of them sound exactly the same
is just really funny to me for some
reason this episode is attached to the
live-action segments opera it's pretty
dull and generic as this show goes so
I'd say skip that and just watch the
cartoon it's a good one
hey do you have any idea how expensive
that is let me guess answer
star Koopa Santa Claus is coming to
Flatbush this is a solid one-two punch
in both the animated and live-action
segments in the live-action Santa Claus
is coming to Flatbush the brothers are
just about as poor as can be they don't
have enough money to buy each other
gifts or even a full Christmas meal they
may be at their lowest but they still
take in an elderly man for the night
who's transportation just broke down
three guesses on who that elderly man is
supposed to be this episode has some
legitimate heart to it since they can't
afford to purchase gifts for each other
Luigi gives Mario his own boots off his
feet while Mario gives his brother his
own special wrench it's a good story for
kids to see and works on that level
the animated star Koopa is a Star Wars
parody but actually done really well a
lot of the time this show missed more
than it hit on these parody episodes so
this was a bit of a surprise
what made everything work was the
trademark line with you may the pasta be
with me may the pop star be with you
[Music]
and the number one FET Super Mario
Brothers Super Show episode is plumbers
Academy slash glass nuts let's all take
a moment and thank the Mario Brothers
for dismantling the Soviet Union in the
live-action episode glass nuts Russian
leader Mikhail Gorbachev makes an
appearance to meet the Mario Brothers
and try their famous pizza it it really
has to be seen to be believed
[Music]
best line though best line first we
watch exciting scenes from Legend of
Zelda then we give pizza attends yes
that's real it's so ridiculous that it
crosses over into being amazing I love
it the cartoon here plumbers Academy is
great as well we see how the mario
brothers became plumbers while also
saving Brooklyn from a sewer flood it's
a really fun episode that might have a
couple familiar faces hidden within the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show will
always be a worthy nostalgic series when
looking back at Mario's TV history these
few episodes should fill your fix if
you're ever curious about revisiting the
show work we need something else quick
do the worry
do the mario swing your arms from side
to side come on it's time to go do the
mario take one step and then again let's
do the mario all together now
keep going way out do the mario swing
[Music]
walls are everday say my out all the
right behind you
[Music]
[Applause]
you